As many of us head home for the day
some animals are just getting their day started.
Sometimes mistaken for hummingbirds,
hungry hawkmths hover in mid-air
sipping nectar from flowers, pollinating
them in return.
These agile insects maneuver
their way around flowers
that sway in the wind.
Often, with little light to see by.
To test how one species of hawkmoth
called the tobacco hornworm keeps up
with its moving flower targets,
researchers created robotic flowers.
There's been a lot of curiosity about
how animals are able to
adjust their visual systems in order to
be able to see
at low light levels.
The hawkmoths didn't seem to mind that the flowers were fake.
As long as they got their sweet sugary
snack.
The researchers tested how well the moths track
the movement of the flowers under two
lighting conditions: early dusk and much
darker moonlight. When the flowers swayed
back and forth
no more than twice per second, the moths
kept up just fine --
regardless of lighting. Any faster
and they started making mistakes
especially in the dimmest light
which also caused them to lag well
behind the flowers.
The researchers think the moths' visual
system
slows down in dim light to boost their
visual acuity,
much like the shutter of a camera.
That works fine as long as an object is
moving slowly
but speed things up images start to blur.
So cameras and moth eyes can't keep up.
But this may not actually matter in the wild.
The researchers also found that the kinds of
flowers these hawkmoths prefer
naturally sway in the wind, no faster
than the insect's visual system can handle.
It's possible plant and pollinator
have co-evolved to be
well matched for each other
as the light fades.